Now, the moment you've been waiting for!
The last performer is Cosmo,
the only herbivore dancer
of the Black Market!
Everyone, please enjoy with your nails
and fangs concealed at all times.
The herbivores of the Black Market
are at the frontline of death.
But I'm still here in this town
because, here, I can really be myself.
I'll squeeze out as much money as I can
from the carnivores before it's too late.
When I die, I'll allow myself
to be devoured to the fullest.
Now… my beasts.
I'm sorry to have kept you waiting.
The smell of a female herbivore,
bare without any clothes
is intensely more fresh and sweet
than meat butchered to eat.
Let me stir up that chaos of appetite
and sexual desire.
You're the ones in the cage.
I'm the ruler here.
Who took away my stepladder?
I see.
It was today.
The end of me.
It's awfully charged up in here.
But the stage is a sacred place.
Rude fellows who disrupt the performance
don't have the right to be on stage.
Ill-mannered guests
will be disciplined by us.
Are you okay?
Why is a herbivore in a place like this?
What I despise the most
aren't the carnivores who want to eat me.
It's the carnivore guests who pity me,
and the herbivores
who come to watch just for fun!
Stand around like that
and you'll be eaten, too!
Children should go home and go to bed!
-Boss…
-What is it?